[Music]
you're very comfortable with your body I
remember it I was watching the Golden
Globes once and I was watching the
pre-show and you're there and Jennifer
Aniston is there and she's walking in
line near you and you see here but
squeeze yeah you walk over to her and
you just start well she starts squeezing
your butt she starts squeezing your butt
and I'm like first of all I have it on
only the movement you get did you did
like this great you did like the creepy
version that's not my creepy that's how
I go in be warned that's how I go in
over the top and down and with this
expression she did she went in for the
butt squeeze and so I thought that's so
nice like women seem to know women are
yeah I think we're really look girls are
cuddly
you know we're tactile we like to
squeeze and touch and hug and snuggle
yeah it doesn't mean it goes any further
it's always good I'm finding a youth for
this long time now we like to get cozy
yeah yeah and she got cozy on the carpet
you've said that you prefer
I think you just named a movie they're
shooting in Van Nuys and they're done
shooting
you